that authorities in germany have started
digging
at a location near the city of hanover
uh they say this is in connection
uh with the disappearance of uh the
young girl madeleine mccann
let's go to sky's grand correspondent
martin brunt for the latest martin
since early morning police and forensic
officers have been
digging in an area just off the road in
this
area it's an allotment area
near hanover we know that christian be
the main suspect in the madeleine mccann
investigation which is being led by a
german prosecutor
once lived in hanover there is
confirmation
from the police and the prosecutor that
this is a search connected
with that investigation but it's not
clear whether they are looking
for potential evidence directly linked
to madeline mccann's disappearance or
something else
involving suspicion around this suspect
he was reportedly linked to the
disappearance of murder of a prostitute
in hanover
in 2010 so it's not clear at this stage
whether that might be the reason for
this dig but it's an extensive area
that's been
cleared over the last few hours
the police are using a mini excavator
according to our colleague on the ground
and trees have been cleared
and it looks it has all the um hallmarks
of an operation that's likely to
go on uh for some time um but
clearly um this is uh an unusual
development i mean in the past of course
there have been digs and searches
in portugal where madeline went missing
in 2007
but this is very much been for the past
two years an operation the madeline
mccann investigation led
by the german prosecution team
and they have said in the past that they
have concrete evidence
that christian b that's how this um
suspect is known under the german
privacy laws
um they have said that they have
concrete evidence of his involvement in
madeleine mccann's disappearance
they believe madley mccann is dead but
it would be i think highly unusual if
they were looking for potential evidence
connected directly to the madeleine
mccann investigation
in germany so far from um from the scene
of the alleged crime of madeleine's um
disappearance
um he lived there in around 2010 we know
that the suspect flitted
a number of times between portugal where
he lived for many years
and his home country germany